alors voici la question combien de fois
mac prononce-t-il alexandrie dans la
chanson les formes avec ce même match ne
s'est pas aller le plus loin de la bonne
réponse a perdu aller vite vite vite
12 27 24 a fait tomber cirque rabat
alors les chéris 50
géraldine maillet vous avez perdu vous
êtes la plus loin d'accord donc que vous
ne réaliserait pas votre rêve votre
iphone et vous allez faire des pas vous
savez quoi vous allez faire du poker
mais chez vous d'accord terre c'est la
question
j'ai pas vu votre réponse matt il
prononce alexandrie dans sa chanson avec
son nez avec son aura onze fois et puis
on se rend crois que c'est plus facile
cet après midi j'ai écouté et j'ai tout
noté à une faute au dossier regarde rien
de regarder non mais c'est bête alors
braqué la première le dossier
c'est là que je pense que la première
akata tu réveiller merci c'est celle qui
râlent quand j'ai tu payes tu arrives à
tuer mais je sais qu'ils ont été cités
entre le foot mais un violent face à
face à s'adapter à son époque et il
valait pas une faune et une veine et de
koh lanta tu fais partie de l'équipe
jaune
[Applaudissements]
de la tribu des pouilles bari série